[Music]
so so welcome to this session in which
we are discussing trust in science with
Peter Doherty and Steven Chu both of
them Nobel laureates as you know and
you'll have met them already today now
I'll run the conversation between us for
a while and then I will come out to the
audience for questions as well which we
shall listen to through these also so
trust in science surveys by people like
the Pew trust charitable trust or it's
awesome re in the UK tell us that
actually scientists are a very trusted
group of people and trust in scientists
is increasing and we as scientists know
that scientists are trustworthy people
but there is also there are also clear
cases where trust in science seems to be
evaporating so first of all let me just
start by saying do you think that people
do have trust in science Steve I think
in general yes they do have a trust but
it's a strange kind of trust because
it's a trust because we see there it's
not a strange country it makes perfect
sense
we have no axe to grind most of us don't
aren't making money on this there's no
financial entanglements but yet in that
same Pew survey there is a strange thing
growing there's a growing uncertainty
about vaccines that vaccines might not
be good for you and yet it vaccines have
had a profound influence on human health
there is a disconnect between what
scientists think what the public thinks
and what some other embedded industries
think about climate change and so they
actually break down and go through this
list and some of these attack points are
genetically modified crops again there's
a fraction of very vocal loud people who
say that this is inherently dangerous
and they tried to stoke fear and
suspicion about
and yet the thing about genetically
modified crops is it's used in the right
way you know Monsanto was very tone-deaf
but if using the right way it can
actually feed many more people keep
developing people's farms functioning in
a way that could feed people with less
pesticides less herbicides and so on and
so again you know there are these
conflicts and I think things like that
are growing yes it's interesting the
vaccines you guys particularly in fact
things that the distrust of vaccines is
interesting because it goes right across
the spectrum in different ways from left
to right yeah a lot of the rejection of
vaccines that we see for instance in
Australia would be on the one hand
you've got very well-to-do women
particularly who reject vaccinations for
various types of reasons to do with
personal empowerment and and and and
they may believe some of the propaganda
around the MMR vaccine and so forth even
though that's been so rigorously refuted
by so many scientific studies and on the
other hand you'll have this sort of
alternative lifestyle community that
will it will it will reject the vaccine
approach though much of actually the
failure to uptake vaccines is simply
disorganization and nothing not getting
around to it then but on the under GM
side it really polarizes on what one
thinks is the left of the political
spectrum and it was very much stood up
on Monsanto and the way they went about
it and the suspicion that Monsanto is
trying to take over the world seed
supply and they're going to control
farmers and they're going to dictate and
and they have dictated in some senses
which have really been quite obnoxious
but then there's the great advantages of
for instance trying to make drought
resistant grains and so with using GM
approaches and of course the the saffron
rice that was developed by by at ETH in
Zurich which could have say
many many lives in the Philippines and
so with but because of the very strong
activity by Greenpeace which is in many
ways that quite admirable organization
there's been a rejection of that so so
it's it's there's nothing it's not that
rejection of science is some sort of
hard right position or hard left
position just will come to GMOs in a
second baby but just your any mere
knowledge is so sticking with the the
vaccine issue it's it's odd in a way
that people do trust in science for many
of their health decisions they they
constantly want to know whether eating
this will make them less like to get
cancer or whatever and yet on vaccines
rather specifically they people seem to
be scared of the science or not or
distrustful of the science well well I
mean what are you doing with the vaccine
I mean you're taking a child a small
child and you're injecting the child
with something and firstly firstly
parents can find that very distressing
secondly a child who is perfectly happy
you take them along you inject them at
the vaccine they'll be grumpy but
possibly because a vaccine is causing an
immune response an immune response
actually causes all sorts of chemicals
to be released that make you feel rather
dull and not very happy and in a small
child you can have a whiny wengie child
then the other factor is of course if
something happens to that child within
the next month or two people will blame
it on the vaccine and and the there are
issues to where vaccines can can
actually do harm I mean it's a
probability relative risk equation and
and that's something that does not
necessarily permeate society the idea
that if you if you vaccinate against a
particular infection that the child
won't get it but but then if you get
this false correlation with something
like the MMR story then they'll know
people get scared off and and there's a
very powerful constituency and a friend
of mine is a guy called Paul Offit who's
is a pediatric infectious disease guy
developed their the rotavirus vaccine
that's of course is a big negative in
the vaccine thing because often just
wants to make profit which couldn't be
further from his authority he
tried to write a very very clear
explanatory book he's written a number
of books on on the mm a store in
measles-mumps-rubella this story that it
causes autism and he went through it in
a very systematic and and very balanced
way and and as a result of that he gets
death threats he won't go on national
television in the United States because
he here he is a middle-aged guy in a
national television format who's who's
operating in the consequence of science
he's up against some very attractive
woman who's appealing to emotional
instincts and and of course is able to
go anywhere she wants with the argument
so I'm not trying to be sexist about
this but this is it just doesn't work
well just to add to that what was
happening was there was a few cases of a
correlation where when you get this
measles mumps rubella vaccine you begin
to be at an age where autism is
beginning to be diagnosed and that has
convinced several mothers that
absolutely was caused of the autism and
there is no real correlation and yet
it's spread over the internet by crazy
well well whenever there's an issue with
the vaccine then it's taken extremely
seriously yes because this is something
you're injecting to children so we had
an instance in Australia for instance
where a formulation of the influenza
vaccine and influenza vaccines are
problematic at various levels I work in
the influenza area but this influenza
vaccine was actually causing fever in
some small children and when children
small turn will get fever they go into
febrile convulsions and at least one
child was severely damaged by this so
that vaccine was just not acceptable but
there was no reason to think it would do
that I mean the flu vaccines are made
every year and all the rest of it so it
was an aberration the vaccine was the
vaccination would stop very quickly but
but so there are some instance like the
measles mumps rubella story is based in
a very bad paper that was published
unfortunately in The Lancet which is a
leading scientific journal should never
be published very limited number of
cases it turns out later they were
selected in various ways which quite
unethical and but what the guy who is
the key to the study was saying not
saying it's not a problem for vaccinate
against
measles mumps and rubella what's a
problem is to combine the three and so
he wasn't trying to say don't vaccinate
he was saying don't use this vaccine and
and that's sort of sort of evolved into
the idea that vaccination is dangerous I
think one of the first things I was told
wit by I think was Francis Collins one
of the first things he was asked by
presidents Trump is what are you gonna
do about vaccines and autism so you know
so it's it's it's in the it's in Trump
world public psyche let's pan out a bit
and talk about bad papers because that's
also something perhaps that is
undermining trust in science there is a
feeling that there is scientific
misconduct out there and that people are
fraudulently publishing papers or these
bad papers are being published of course
it's a very small number but when you
have things like retraction watch going
on that sort of highlights this to the
public do you think there's a problem
with scientific misconduct or I let's go
with bad papers let's start with bad
papers there are a lot of bad papers in
the sense that so here publish that
you're maybe not as careful about all
the controls you have to do and the
pressure to publish is mounting mounting
mounting and so there are many things
especially in the bio I come from
physics which you know there's a
theoretical basis and there are other
things you can do and when I start going
in biology 25 30 years ago in the early
90s that long ago I heard the expression
in my hands this is what we get
that's not science
you're supposed to be publishing
something that anyone can reproduce and
and so so this is one of the issues and
so there's a lot of things so I think
scientists have to take up a bit higher
responsibility the number of purposely
fraudulent things is very small but
there's this other thing that is
encroaching so it reproducibility of
papers is becoming in geology a huge
problem
has become environments and yes part of
it is the complexity of these systems I
think physics looking at physics as an
outsider a physicists on the whole
pretty straight
I mean physicists are trained as
scientists that they're very bright
people as anything
I mean Alfred Nobel thought the
businesses were the smartest people on
earth that's why the people who sit on
the stage first the physicists and the
chemists then the Medeco and then the
and then the literature got a person and
then the the economists sort of bought
their way into the herbal price later I
don't know whether we're going to
survive this there is a major there are
cases of major fraud in physics and
Stevens very familiar with this because
some of you may have read the book
plastic fantastic hmm which is out a
major fraud at the bell lab yes and for
various reasons people weren't watching
the store and this happened this guy was
just faking in biomedicine we do have
people who are faking we've had some
instances where people have made up data
and sometimes they got away with it
because what they made up actually later
turned out to be true and and in and
several cases where that's happened the
people have exposed them are the young
people in their labs because they're
dedicated to the idea that they're
probing truth and here they find the guy
they're working for is a professional
liar and so that that has been effective
but the other more disturbing factor is
that with some of the enormous ly
complex studies that are being done
particularly in molecular science
there's an enormous difficulty in
repeating them and that is really
problematic and and I don't my personal
approach has always been you check and
you check and then you always get into
some what we call an in vivo system
which is over a lab mouse or a human
being and check it in in in a real world
but a lot of the science is not checked
in that way all sorts of things can go
wrong in science that stung would say
cancer cell lines I mean if a cancer
cell line gets infected with mycoplasma
for instance
and often people are not as careful with
checking in that it can give you totally
erroneous results so so it is a concern
but the point about biomedical science
is it's moving forward at an incredible
rate to actually find solutions we are
getting incredible solutions to real
disease problems very fast but yeah true
but but I mean Steve people will know
you as a physicist they may not know
that you also have now a foot in the
camp of biomedicine that you help chairs
in both uh-oh in molecular yes I mean
here from the medical school yeah so
does do worry very much about this
growing problem of the reproducibility
that it will in some way undermine trust
in science because although I don't
think the biomedical community have
quite sorted out why things are so
difficult to reproduce well I think
Peter said it very concisely it's really
complicated okay and but but there's
something else in my lab if a graduate
and post like does something the first
standard is they have to repeat it in my
lab someone else in my lab has to repeat
it that standard is not followed in
every lab and so this is something and
you want it to be more bulletproof when
you publish a paper and a protocol you
want it passed on to at least one more
other person I remember when I was first
doing biophysics optical tweezers gluing
little poly scenes seers to DNA and you
can whip around and I was talking about
for two years my colleagues asked me
have you published this yet I said no
not yet
well why not I said it only works half
the time half the time for two years you
got to be kidding the same year as a
neuroscientist and prisoner and Stan
prisoner developed the prion hypothesis
the infectious protein idea that at the
base of what we call the spongiform
encephalopathies or in as a foreman euro
pathologists the spongy brain rots you
know what to be diagnosed with one of
those I tell you but before Stan coded
that thing there was that there was a
particular assay that was done that was
showing some extremely
possible positive results and it was it
was called the Pam essay because the
only person who could do it was a woman
called pam pam was flood all around the
world she went to different labs that
check I saw a magician today part of the
problem now is when I started in
biomedical science back in the 1960s 70s
there were three or four of us on a
research paper and we all understood
what was going on we knew the technology
and we could make wonderful
generalizations because we couldn't do
the experiments it was much more fun and
we were having my theoretical physicist
and that's not really true but now
because of the enormous power of
technology much of which has actually
come from the physicists and the
engineers who have given us these
wonderful instruments and then from the
computational people who do the analyses
but because of that power of technology
every subfield has become much more
complex and much more specialized and
when we do a study say a cancer study or
infectious disease study we may be
involving so many different
subspecialties in that analysis that
nobody on that research paper is
actually right across the whole thing
it's not just not possible to be right
across it and so I mean Trust is
essential within science actually just
as an aside when I remember watching the
press conference from the LHC results
and I was amazed by how much agreement
there was between people when they were
looking at the results and I asked a
theoretical physicist how come
everybody's in agreement and he said
well the thing about physics
experimental physics physics is that
it's so expensive that we all have to
agree before we do the experiment
and I don't know that's true but is
there a problem in physics it seems to
be that partly that the theoreticians
aren't in many areas are leading the
experimentalists ah none not really
first when there's a big announcement
with the collaboration that spans
several hundred institutions not people
there the haggling has done before it
goes to public press now and so there is
some haggling the announcement of
gravity waves there were three months of
very paranoid to make sure that this
wasn't an artifact that they really
wanted to check everything you know it's
really months it was beginning to leak
out in January but they really held it
wraps in this in terms of theory versus
experiment absolutely true that the
Higgs was predicted long before and it
was a confirmation it was a in a certain
sense very disappointing because theory
was right and even the theorists don't
wanted they wanted a surprise and every
every physicists every scientist wants a
surprise and and the biggest fear now
with the Large Hadron Collider is so far
no surprises and that is a real fear
billions of dollars no surprises you
know we need to be told something we
don't know so we can think of something
and so the theory the stanch local
standard model has been too successful
whereas in biomedicine is it true that
people you know that people are just
putting things out very fast there's
there's possibly too fast I don't know
what because things are happening so
fast and because the the possibilities
are so enormous I mean for instance when
I started back in the nineteen seventies
when I was doing the week we won the
Nobel Prize for there were no none of
what we call cytokines chemokines I mean
I think the first one was interleukin 2
which now there are enormous numbers of
them and some of these molecules which
are produced during immune responses
have been found to have enormous
therapeutic
potential in various ways we for
instance we're getting a story now for
colon cancer we ran a molecule I think
it's in toluca not 11 maybe it may have
the wrong number there are so many of
these things is actually clearly
promoting the growth of the cancer so
here you've got a molecule that's
designed to try and reject a pathogen a
virus a bug or something which when it
gets into a cancer situation it's
actually helping the cancer grow we
we've long suspected that much of that
sort of thing is happening but it looks
as though if you can block that you can
actually slow the progression of this
particular cancer very very dramatically
and and that's happened all across the
board with various of these molecules
which are now we know if you block them
you can decrease the the the suffering
from rheumatoid arthritis there are
other situations where you can massively
drop back the relapses in multiple
sclerosis and so forth this has all been
happening very quickly and almost on an
ad-hoc basis and no enormous
intellectual component to this it's a
matter of just going ahead and testing
it and testing it properly but but you
shouldn't go away the impression is
biology and medicine are racing ahead
and physics is not I think if and the
scale of very large machines very large
budgets like high-energy physics Large
Hadron Collider gravity waves absolutely
takes decades if you look at other
things
nanotechnology what's happening in
electrochemistry some of the things that
I'm actually actively involved in today
it's racing ahead just as fast and so so
this is part of physics physical
chemistry of material science very
profound deep understandings the ability
to make new materials that completely
enable new biological probes to new
batteries is racing and so it's a very
exciting time to be alive if we look
well and one of the big problems with
drugs that causes drug delivery yeah and
we're looking very much to the nano
scientist so substantially chemists I
think oh and also physicists and to
actually it's a form of material science
to try and get delivery systems that
work infinitely better than the delivery
systems we have I mean once you get into
there
pew ticks that there's this sort of net
nexus between physics chemistry and and
biology with with us often on the sort
of rather the measurement in rather
innovation end yeah the last three years
I'm actually I daresay sadly I'm
learning chemistry don't be a third
chair but but you know you know physics
and biology but I said some of the
things I wanted to do in biology and in
energy means I had to learn chemistry
and so okay I'm gonna have to learn
chemistry and it's been fun you know my
advisor
what's horrified that I was even using
lasers to try to cool and trap atoms he
said you have to stick to the basic
fundamental really important stuff and
he would be even more horrified if I was
becoming a chemist as a chemist I'll
just sit here and take it one more topic
to discuss before we go to the audience
the role of the media in trust in
science do you think that it's a huge
generalization but do you think the
media are doing a good job in portraying
science to the general public
Steve no for a lot of reasons but one of
the things that's the driving force in
the media is to sell copy because the
print media the televised media all the
media are competing with these bubble
knitter Internet things where you only
talk to your friends and old friends
talk to their friends and they don't
talk to others and they wanted to
compete and so how do you compete you
actually present the other side the
alternative view and they will search
long and hard for some alternative view
and so unfortunately some very minority
position then almost gets elevated to
the same position as as you know much
more serious science and so that is very
disturbing the other thing is
the quality of scientific employers the
number of quality science reporters is
diminishing and and that that's a
problem yeah I mean particularly a
problem in the print media where the
under enormous pressure because online
information free information and so
forth and and so that we've been losing
a lot of a lot of our good science
journalists but we also have middie a
very substantial media organizations for
instance which will simply not report
anything factual on climate change they
will go to any alternative source and
that I mean Fox News for instance which
will will simply in anything serious
they if they report it they will
trivialize it and so we're getting a
deliberate dissembling in elements in
the media on the other hand of course we
have sort of people who are professional
science communicators the david
attenborough's the Brian Cox's and all
the rest of us who who try to do the
right thing and try to do a reasonably
good job and unfortunately it doesn't
really I think it often fails to get
across to people the essence of science
and how it actually works and what it
does and what it's what our strengths
and limitations are it often comes
across as sort of gee wizards and this
wonderful stuff but but the other thing
about on one side you says what we
reported this story and that's it and
the other side just wants to repeat over
and over and over again because as I
said this morning you know I may not
have said it in public but I said it in
you know in breakfast Lucy from peanuts
cartoons she has her hand she's shaking
and says I may not be right but I'm loud
and and the present the current
president United States is is all that
so I'm following a track you started
that medium maybe not doing a good job
in getting across the way that science
operates but perhaps that's also true of
our education generally that when people
go through their science classes in
school they don't come out knowing what
science is they come out thinking that
sart's delivers a set of facts that
could be trusted yes you know to
actually get
you actually you really have to do it at
some stage I think and there was a very
interesting move some years back but I
suspect I guess savings well on top of
this but this idea of physics first
remember that movement does that
actually get traction no it hasn't but
but but let me go back to what you said
is that right what the way we teach
Sciences in high school and in college
is here's a set of facts and there are
now modern educators are looking at what
you know and how what we consider expert
thinking which is you know okay here are
some facts how do you actually do
something and and actually begin to
assess evidence which is what we really
want to teach and after the class they
actually were worse than when they
started
because they were learned here's what to
memorize and so we're totally rewriting
education in physics chemistry
especially is to say no we want to teach
people how to think and so that's the
most important thing and where we were
going backwards and so this is a new
realization that we were doing it all
wrong it's only when you get to graduate
school and postdoc that you begin to
teach people how to think again but boy
most people don't go to graduate school
and become postdocs they have to learn
this in grade school high school and
college there's something about our
education system that actually turns
large numbers of people off science
totally and and and you get people who
are highly intelligent people educated
in the more arts side of things if they
come across anything that's science for
instance in a book that will immediately
drop it immediately turn off and I
that's pretty unfortunate given that
given this transformational power of
science on our lives that the fact that
were always having all having to make
science-based decisions all the time
whether it's about climate change or
GMOs or whatever it's pretty important
that we should have some kind of proper
grounding in it to enable us to make the
right decisions so right yes it seems a
pretty fundamental challenge a grand
challenge for Humanity if you like to
have a generator to have the next
generations come up and be ready for
this well the great news
is that you know like the four or five
steps to reform or whatever or sobriety
at least we know we were doing it wrong
before
so that's the first step and and we're
doing a lot of experiments at Stanford
and everywhere else I think to try to
say how do you get you know how do you
measure how people can actually assess
information and I think and how do you
actually get them to do it one of the
things that we found really powerful is
you start to ask questions in class and
let them go in a little group of one two
or three
for a few minutes and then come back and
that begins to cement a lot of things
and so it's not the professor drones on
they take the notes and everything you
don't need to take the notes it's all
you can post it and everything else and
getting people engaged in real-time is
very very important yes I suppose that
is sorry I keep on finding new tracks to
go but I suppose the social side of
science is so important to get across
because again I think science is quite
often thought of as a rather
individualistic activity yeah it's a
very cooperative activity basically I
mean the a good laboratory is really a
sort of social social microcosm isn't it
I mean you've got all these interactions
going on and a lot of what we do because
you have to do so many different types
of measurements you'll have a whole
bunch of people all coming together on a
particular particular experiment or a
particular problem and working very
closely together on it so it's I think
something people miss if they move out
of Sciences that is that sort of
collegiality and cooperativity questions
now's your chance yes please um there's
a microphone which you need you need to
use a microphone so we can hear you if
you said to me I mean maybe we don't
what's your suggestion for future
biomedical or just researchers in
raising or increasing truth in research
in science what's your suggestion for
for increasing truth I mean for those
trust in science truth
working with young biomedical scientists
I and I in which I've been doing sort of
50 years I I don't think I've ever come
across a situation where I've thought
that anyone's faking anything I've done
what Steve this is I've had people
repeat things maybe ask the question in
a somewhat different way so it's not
positive not so obvious that it's a
repeat
I think young scientists particularly on
a very very very dedicated to this idea
of integrity of the integrity of the
science it's it can be a bit corrupted
lighter and to that I yes to that I
would would add that there the there's a
flowering of new methods of measuring
things there are physical methods there
are biochemical methods there are social
methods all and so all these different
tools can be used to have to actually
figure out what's really going on the
reproducibility has to be a standard in
every lab a very high standard of
reproducibility and the willingness to
go on tests yourself by having it could
be wrong get a different way of
measuring and even a different tool and
that also adds to that I mean you know
the criticism of climate science where
people say these people are faking and
that sort of thing is just ridiculous
because you look at a climate science
group I'd not might feel but I chaired a
big research group Advisory Committee
for a time in this area and basically
what you've got is very very smart
people trained principle in physics
oceanography these sorts of areas these
are a really smart very dedicated very
professional people the idea that they
could be corrupted to falsehood by some
sort of conspiracy of the elders is
absolutely absurd I mean it simply could
not and would not happen it's just a
totally contrary to the reality of this
if you say they're corrupted long enough
people might believe it yeah people say
it and yeah okay thank you
there's a question over here please
I would like to as a journalist to
continue on the media track and I fully
agree about what you said that news
media today is its logic is managed by
economical fact factors but sometimes I
have a feeling also that journalists are
not fully I can't their subjects when
they interview researchers or scientists
and have some sum of over over too much
respect for scientists and also is there
a responsibility from the scientists
side whom I I think sometimes think
generally star stupid and they can say
whatever they like and it gets published
without being criticized or scrutinized
do you have a comment on that either my
experience with journalists particularly
being in Australia which is dominated a
bit by Murdoch media which is
problematic the and and the the very
actually a very small number of science
journalists so that you would find
yourself being questioned about some
sort of science issue but by someone who
basically reports on football it would
always put it in an adversarial have the
serial mode because that's the way they
think about things very difficult to
actually get get something across I sort
of we sort of gave up actually on the
idea of making it work better so what we
did it was an initiative from a former
newspaper editor who come out to
Australia he edited The Scotsman and the
observer in the UK a man called Andrew
Jaspan and he come out to it at the
Melbourne age which is quite a
reasonable newspaper not Murdoch and and
then they decided to go down market so
he left but he got this idea of
formulating a new type of media which is
essentially
it's online but what he did he said we
will tap all the expertise in
universities we'll get people to write
under 800 word pieces on their their
area of expertise and we'll put that
through a professional newsroom of
editors and journalists and and this led
to a production called the the
conversation it's one word and this has
been an honestly successful they built
in all sorts of things firstly everyone
who writes for it makes a
conflict-of-interest statement which is
published with every article and they
have to have some sort of academic
affiliation to keep out the the
criminals in the think tanks I mean
these people that just crooks on the
hole so so basically that caught on in
Australia we get the articles come out
there you simply sign up for it it comes
to your email inbox every morning six
days a week and any article that's
published in that can be lifted by a
newspaper or by any other media outlet
as long as they acknowledge where it
comes from and republish so many of the
articles are republished and and they're
very good authoritative clearly written
and easily understandable articles this
is now driving a lot of media activity
in Australia it's not it's now running
in the United Kingdom it's the French
took it up it's running in Africa it's
running in the United States so take a
look at it I mean it's the conversation
one word dot e-d-u or something like
that and and just take a look at it
because it's it's it's actually making
the the academic whether it be political
science or science or social or anything
part of the communication thing but not
in a way where it's an echo chamber like
Facebook or Twitter and so forth but I
think scientists have the responsibility
to communicate what they're doing and I
haven't actually had that reaction with
most journalists it's not adversarial
and there's a genuine attempt to try to
learn what we do
and and Einstein famously said many
times things but he said make simple
things as simple as possible but no more
and and he was a master at reducing
things to very simple but absolutely
correct statements and so I think as
scientists that should be the ideal and
so if a journalist or the public or
whatever does not understand what we're
doing it's largely our fault
and so if scientists have that attitude
rather than you know I'm so smart and if
you don't understand what I'm doing
shame on you
it can go a long way to actually getting
a much more receptive audience I was
actually more referring by the
journalism of finding that one in ten
thousand and one five thousand that
willing to say something where it
doesn't represent a the balanced view of
science just just to pick up on
something else you said do people
respect you too much as scientists or
indeed as Nobel laureate is that does
that create a barrier to the sort of
questions that journalists can ask you
it's certainly true then after you get a
Nobel Prize something seems to happen I
never really fully understood this until
after I got the Nobel Prize and it
wasn't only on December 10 in 1997 I'm
on stage and look out and said oh my
gosh this is a big deal and because what
I said to myself before that is I'm no
smarter than I was before October and
all the people got Nobel Prizes before
me that I knew didn't get suddenly
smarter they were they were either smart
or stupid before and they were the same
and so but the public has a different
view of that and and so I so you try to
guard against it and try as hard as you
can not to ramble on
but it's so tempting
do your inside communications you do
your utmost to try and tell the story in
a way that your audience is going to
understand it
and so so it's what sort of a learning
curve for most of us because most of us
before this for the Nobel Prize we don't
spend much time on the public stage but
but once you're on the public side you
learn a lot of things very quickly but
one thing is that no matter how crazy a
question may seem and we're not getting
that from this audience but how crazy it
may seem the last thing you ever do is
humiliate the question in any way
whatsoever because as soon as you do
that even if they think the question is
crazy too you lose your audience you
have to try the best you can do is say
someone comes along and said I don't
believe in vaccinations I believe if I
feed my child the right way they'll have
a great immune system the best you can
do is is try to sow a little seed of
doubt just very deep gently and you
can't do any better than that so you do
your best but we're not trained as
science communicators we have to learn
it I see two more questions I promise
you yes you're there Lots but we'll have
to move quickly
shorter answers below so in Sweden I'm
in high school right now and in the last
year of high school you everyone like
makes a project and a science project
and when I tried to search for sources
articles most articles were pretty
expensive for the average person and
like the only way we could reasonably
use them was to find someone that was in
a university or something to give them
to us and if it's like as if you're not
inside academia it's really hard to get
in to get like resources of course more
and more and more science now is going
to open access where the scientist pays
ahead of time so I mean publication of
an article even even online cost
something and the scrutiny the reviewing
and all the rest of it so so in many
cases we're now paying ahead of
publication basically so that the
article will be an open-access article
the
issue is though for many people and
you're no doubt more sophisticated than
most but for many people if you contact
look at an open-access scientific paper
a minute
it's a totally different type of writing
it can be quite incomprehensible and you
can come to cut some quite wrong
conclusions if you don't understand how
that process actually works and how the
publication process works but I think
I'm not sure physics I don't know but
but I think more and more of
publications is to open ax well well
first let me make a small correction the
scientists actually pay whether it's
open access or not paid charges the only
the only exceptions would be the
for-profit journals and nature of
science itself but but virtually every
other whether you pay pay charges you
pay extra you can get it open access and
what you describe is a serious problem
and so one is trying to figure out how
to do that yes these articles could be
very technical but the first step is you
know how do you give the wider audience
this open access the paywall is still a
very serious barrier yes yeah because
although open access is going there
still there's an increasing dominance of
those top-tier journals that people are
trying to get into to get their names
made in science and those are not
offering themselves for free in them
well yes
after years sometimes many of the
articles are incomprehensible even it
here in the field I mean some of them by
the time they're reviewed and reira
viewed and so forth what may have been a
perfectly clear ox exposition from the
original author can end up as something
that's simply a verbal morass and so
what we have is people writing what we
call news and views to actually explain
what the papers saying ok so ok we're
running short of time but there is a
question here I'll take one here please
yes quick quick question thank you could
you talk a little bit about the online
teaching platform such as Kucera
and so forth because it becomes more and
more popular nowadays especially for
emerging economies so can we say it can
be a good solution for the delivering
the trust of all knowledge or science to
those absolutely in fact you know why
you know I'm learning chemistry I
actually go to Khan Academy and they
teach me what's radix Reduction
you know reduction oxidation I'm not so
proud I'm willing to admit that these
things are great and and they are
wonderful and you know what the sad
thing is a lot of the online courses
with the interaction between the student
and the machine is actually making a
bigger dent in education than the formal
lecture and so we have to up our game as
lecturers in universities because it's
going to be very good and also gets to
be universal education in many places
where you don't have places like
Stanford it's right particularly in a
country like Australia with you know
it's an enormous country and people are
stuck in country towns someone of
someone with small children at home for
instance can access information we have
well-organized
essentially distance education for a
very long time and that is moved into
this type of area with exactly the type
of technology that Stephens talking
about that basically it's initially when
people started to do this they've found
if they had to answer the questions from
their students coming back it was taking
all their time then they analyzed it and
they found there were a limited number
of questions they developed essentially
machine answers and everyone is
perfectly happy with that and it works
extremely well so there are not that
many variants in fact sir fantastic ok
well thank you very much indeed I'm
afraid we're out of time but I've
learned a lot from this conversation I
hope you have - one thing I've learnt is
that you use Khan Academy so I'm going
straight back to tell my twelve-year-old
son that if Steve's true use is it you
can spend 40 minutes on it this evening
thank you to both my panelists and to
all
you audience for being in thank you
[Applause]